the screenwriters are among the most
outspoken articulate and surly groups in
Hollywood they insisted that their
awards be given by a past president of
the Academy and someone who had been
nominated for an Oscar at least eight
times and won at least twice now this
person must also be intelligent literate
and the author of at least one
best-selling book so Decatur - their
ridiculous win here is the magnificently
versatile miss Betty Davis
thank you so very much
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material from another medium
are Eleanor parry David and Lisa
Robert bolt Lawrence of Arabia large
Amir Nabokov Lolita William Gibson the
miracle worker Horton Foote's To Kill a
Mockingbird the envelope please
the winner is horton Foote
accepting on behalf of horton Foote with
the Alan Pakula
but horton Foote I'd like to express
deep gratitude the members of the
Academy and for all of us associated
with the Kill a Mockingbird I would like
to express our deep gratitude to mr.
Horton put thank you
the nominees for best story and
screenplay written directly for the
screen our story and screenplay by any
old dick when changing Alfredo Giamatti
and Pietro Jimmy for divorce
Italian style story by charles kaufmann
screenplay by charles kaufmann and
Wolfgang Reinhardt for Freud story and
screenplay by alain rob Binet for last
year at Marienbad story and screenplay
by stanley shapiro and nate monitor for
that touch of meek story and screenplay
by Ingmar Bergman but through a glass
darkly the envelope please
thank you sir the winner is those three
difficult Italian aise divorce italian
style
translations now you have great okay
can you do that hey cool hey I was
absolutely sure not not to have anything
so the surprise and the joy and thank
you
I know one of my people would show up
eventually tonight